what's up get humans thank you so much
for joining us for another episode of
spectrum this one is sponsored by our
friends at Skillshare so make sure you
stick around all the way to the end to
hear how 2020 can be the year of
exploring new skills and getting Glaus
and creativity for now
enjoy the episode I was told that
something was wrong with me a lot I have
had teachers actually stand me up in
front of the class and say I was gonna
be homeless because I didn't learn like
everybody else
I regret dropping out three two one go I
actually have dropped out four times
three times out of high school and then
out of college I dropped out one
semester I think if I didn't take the
time to really realize who I was and
really figure myself out I wouldn't be
where I am right now and I probably
wouldn't even be here if I can be honest
in school they require you so much for
you to be presence but when it comes to
how you're doing with your mental health
or how situations are kind of going at
home they don't really count in the
first year to maybe three or four years
after dropping out I felt really
confident about my decision I was living
in a really nice place driving nice cars
making money wearing nice clothes but I
think I kind of fell into a trap because
the entertainment industry led me out of
school I started getting myself
accustomed to this lifestyle and it
didn't allow me the time that I think a
lot of people who go to college have to
actually figure out what they want I
think it is helpful to have those
formative years in college you you
switch a class or you try something new
for me I'm like selling a $10,000 watch
to pay the bills while I try to figure
something else out and then running back
to the entertainment
industry at the same time those years of
self-discovery and everything I had that
because I dropped out yes I dropped out
when I was 13 I had all of those years
who just like what do I want to do and
then I found out what I wanted to do
super early because I had the time I
wasn't able to live you know with my
parents while I figured this out my
parents got split up my my house got
sold I didn't have anywhere to live so
by 17 I had my own apartment if I if I
don't know what I want to do I can't pay
my rent the education system failed me
three two one go
when I think education system I think
what they're teaching me what the
curriculum is I'm sure like when P other
people think of it they think of the
finances of it I think what am i
learning in the classroom whether the
teachers explaining to me
I think there's problems with the
education system but it's up to you to
recognize what those problems are and
kind of work around them if you blame
someone or like a system for your own
mistakes then that's kind of where you
know you to be angry and not really
changing I think both of you touched on
the subject that was like basically
you're supposed to recognize if it's not
working for you which is a really adult
way to think of that because now you're
in this mindset I was told that
something was wrong with me a lot I've
had teachers actually stand me up in
front of the class and say that I was I
was gonna be homeless because I didn't
learn like everybody else I was
diagnosed with depression when I was 2
years old so when I started going to
school I started reaching out for help
and the same thing that happened to me
they told me that I was gonna fail that
I wasn't strong enough to be in this
world and that I was not gonna be
successful and I ended up moving here I
was like it'll probably be different now
moving to a new country I'm moving to a
new school environment and I started
getting bullied again I tried talking to
the principal side or talking to the
deans I tried talking to so many people
and they just told me the same it's you
and it's your fault
so I feel like you failed me because
it's not like I didn't reach out for
help in school is the fact that I asked
for help and I didn't get it and then I
got blamed for that I feel ashamed for
dropping out 3 2 1 go part of me is
still bothered that like my parents are
like bothered that I didn't finish
school and that I don't really have any
drive or care to go back to school but I
mean I love the hustle you know I got
into the industry I wanted to be in when
I was 20 21 years old and it was solely
off of me
is taking internships I didn't go to
school to study I'm not lazy so I guess
that's really important when I first had
a dropout I called my roommates that day
I was supposed to be flying back to tell
them oh by the way I'm not coming back
because I was so embarrassed to be like
I can't afford school so like for my
entire second semester I was living here
everyone thought I was still in Hawaii
so then when I would see people in June
they'd be like how was your first year
in Hawaii like did you love it and I
would lie I would say yeah it was
amazing like I had the best first year I
used to do something similar whenever
someone would ask me where I went to
school I would just be like oh like UCLA
oh cool instead of being like Oh what
are you doing a why well run I gotta
explain my whole life to you but I also
I like what ty said you just said I'm
not lazy and that's a huge stereotype
like oh you were too lazy to finish
school and I think that that should
totally be broken because a lot of the
time it's like I have to work harder
because I didn't go to school like now I
have to basically pick up the pieces
there is little youtube it teaches you a
million things and I've learned so many
things from the internet that I could
have learned a scoop what I'm in for
free on my house in the comfort of my
bed and I appreciate that dropping out
changed how my family saw me 3 2 1 go
[Music]
most of my uncle's my dad they didn't
graduate high school into like way later
on in life most of my uncle's graduate
got like a GED and prison and stuff like
that so I don't feel like it's
necessarily frowned upon I think it's
just more that stereotype of life I
didn't get a degree when I was supposed
to get one so you should I think my
parents had like a vision for what they
wanted me to do for a long time I was
just like to become pharmacist and then
I decided to do it like at that time
when I was 18 I didn't know what to do
so I applied to like one of the
accelerator programs and when I dropped
out that was like the end of their world
like they didn't know what to do with me
when I left school I like opened up so
much I became like who I truly was that
was so oppressed just like came out and
I became like so happy and like so much
more extroverted than I already am and
my family of course they saw that and
they were like okay great my immediate
family my mom brother dad they're all
very supportive of it because they've
known me from a young age and know what
type of person I am my girlfriend her
family is different
they actually make their livings in
education so when she kind of brought
this guy home who dropped out of high
school it was kind of unexpected now
these people are my family but um I
still feel like I have to prove myself I
work in TV and even when my shows are
off the air
I still feel like I have to justify the
fact that like I'm getting up every day
and I'm doing something I'm the only
child already on my mom side so there is
a pressure already there I have to
afford for a phone it's only me and my
mom and as much as I love my family and
I wish them the best when it comes to my
own life I don't let those comments get
to me any more because it'll make my
life more miserable and instead of
finding myself and who I am I'm gonna
destroy myself because my family it is
really they're really critical when it
comes to school especially because I'm
here and I'm living the American dream
and I'm supposed to be able to do this
this and that but what if that box
doesn't fit for myself am I just
supposed to do it to make all of you
happy or to make myself happy I would
like my children to complete their
education three two one go
[Music]
my mom's a teacher and my dad works for
the local school board so I've just
always been surrounded by education and
for me I feel like my kids don't have to
I will encourage them to go to school
but if they could figure out what they
want to do without having to go to
school then great I was so miserable
because my whole life I was trying to
make other people happy I don't want
them to feel like I can be myself
because my mom is gonna is not going to
be proud of me
the privilege that we have today to say
that we don't want something for our
kids is like it's definitely a privilege
because I think I understand where my
parents come from in terms of what they
want for us the immigrant mentality of
like wanting your kid to go through the
education system is like really
entrenched in that culture I don't like
fault people who think that way but for
me right now if I had a kid I probably
you know just when I wouldn't want
anything for them I would want them to
want something and then I'll support
that at the end of the day you're going
to want your kid to do something and for
me at least it's going to be how I came
up I want you to like do what you what
you feel is best for you sure I'll have
my opinion but I will never ever
pressure my kid to do something that
they do not want to do
[Applause]
hey guys thank you so much for watching
that as a spectrum we have so much new
and exciting content coming your way
this year speaking of what are some of
your goals this year Dan me and my
girlfriend really want to redecorate our
place
sorry guys Dan is not single but good
news is school sure has a perfect class
for you it's called Sal your space bring
creativity to interior design and for
all you guys out there they have a
digital poster design class
instagram-worthy photography anything
you can think of Skillshare has a class
for you
Skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meanings with so much to explore real
projects to create and the support of
fellow creatives Skillshare empowers you
to accomplish real growth classes are
designed to fit your busy routine so you
can move your creative journey forward
without putting life on hold it's
incredibly affordable guys less than $10
a month for an annual subscription we're
just so much better than those pricey
in-class alternatives so make 2020 a
year where you learn new skills deepen
your existing passions and just get lost
in creativity you might be surprised by
what you find on Skillshare website so
click the link in the descriptions get
to three months of premium membership
and explore your creativity as always
thank you so much for watching make sure
to subscribe leave a comment below
follow us on Instagram and we'll see you
next time